après de kim kardashian maintenant ça
c'est le gros scandale aussi aux états
unis est ce qu est la honte de ses
enfants ou pas elle retouches avec test
une avec plein de trucs sur instagram le
visage de ses enfants
certains disent que justement elle se
fout du monde parce que du coup l
habitude d enfants aux visages parfaits
ou contart qu'à la honte de ses enfants
regardez kim kardashian on retouche ten
les photos de ses enfants sur son compte
instagram site en tout cas ce que
pensent les fans de la starlette qui ont
poupart et la même soirée pyjama publié
par kylie jenner la soeur de kim et par
kim elle même après les fans
la forme du visage de chicago la fille
de kim et ses cheveux sont différents
persos nous on voit juste un filtre en
plus en tout cas cette semaine ses
volées de bois vert pour la femme que
kanye west
[Musique]
alors une création qu'est ce qu'on en
pense benoît là là on est vraiment dans
son domaine galy aussi mais c'est moi
d'abord aux touches ces gamins sur un
non alors elle retouche pas une mais des
filtres pour un peu celui mais la peau
et où moi je trouve ça très grave
effectivement c'est un rappel la peau
d'un enfant à deux recommandent aussi
venu la peau d'un enfant de deux ans oui
je trouve ça très grave
d'accord je suis en train avec des fois
ça ça me rappelle un peu les mini-miss
ou leur met des fausses dents des faux
cheveux kim kardashian a toujours été
dans le too much
donc voilà fort bien son nom c'est kim
kardashian ouest avait complètement à
l'ouest donc elle à moi je trouve ça
grave qu'elle le fasse pour elle oui
qu'elle le fasse pour ses enfants non on
le sait ça peut exagérer quand même
le filtre il est hyper les gens là pas
non plus rajouter des fossiles mais
denis des paillettes partout c'est quand
même très joueurs et des deux pour coup
mais c'est ça vous choque pas ça vous
est une réalité la myriade de 2,2 me
créer vos enfants ou ses dires voulait
trouver moche en paix tu sais tu vois
que ton enfant c'est à dire que ce soit
filtre toute la journée toi aussi ce
qu'est ce que tu pilot mme patou
saint-guillaume parce que ses 36 ans je
veut cacher un peu mon âge un enfant
soit beau et leiria rien fait du tout ce
que ce qui est stupide dans cette
histoire là c'est pas tellement qu'elle
met des filtres à ses enfants parce que
les limites aujourd'hui tout le monde
est petit filtre c'est que dans cette
famille de débiles s'écoute dans cette
famille de débiles profonds la nuit là
ils prennent tous les mêmes photos ils
prennent tous les mêmes photos et du
coup ils se rendent pas compte qu'ils
prennent les mêmes photos et qui postent
les mêmes photos il y en a une qui met
un filtre et l'autre regardez les photos
c'est les mêmes mais c'est pas vraiment
la même personne qui se consultent pas
jusqu'à vous êtes quelqu'un de courageux
je ne sais pas si ça vient québécoise un
peu française ils étaient tous louent sa
blanche une américaine il y va il
balance